the secret of a great hash brown are the
potatoes
i prefer using really nice waxy potatoes
they cook better but more importantly
hold themselves together
we're not gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes we're actually gonna grate them
the potatoes get really nice and crispy
i mean seriously crispy now the onion
that way you get that nice balance of
that onion flavor running through
every little shard of potato
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
and then squeeze all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there really important
the more liquid you remove the crispier
your hash browns will be
nice large pan put that on once the
pan's hot
pour in a good glug of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms how important it is
to have your pan
nice and hot so it seals
the grated potato onion together so take
the spoon
and just pat it down what we're trying
to do now is get it really nice and
compact
go around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter
you just slip them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelised
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over
quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over and then slide it back in
very quickly you see the color
we've got on there now that nice
crispy texture of the potato
i'm going to use the hash brown as a bed
for my baked eggs
crack in your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling
of the cayenne to make the eggs a little
bit spicy
then into a preheated oven for six to
eight minutes
meanwhile onto my bacon and i'm giving
it a classic american twist
now one thing i could never get my head
around when i first started eating lots
of american breakfast was the
sweetness from the bacon i've grown up
to love that combination of smoky sweet
flavors
and it's so easy pan on and simply olive
oil
brown sugar salt and pepper and butter
bacon in and as it cooks it becomes
irresistibly caramelized and golden
brown
10 for gas and my glazed bacon
absolutely ready beautiful now my hash
browns and baked eggs
are ready wow look at that
beautiful just put your spatula
underneath there
onto your plate and that bacon sets
beauty on top of the baked eggs and that
hash brown underneath and
you can see why the best breakfasts in
the world
are always in america
this is an all-american superhero offer
breakfast
eggs baked in hash browns with glazed
bacon
birch muesli traditionally gets made the
night before and left in the fridge i
find that a little bit too heavy
and slightly stodgy so it's the same
principles
but a lot lighter first thing the
yoghurt
i think live and raw milk yogurt are
best they're packed with calcium
enzymes and probiotics which help your
body absorb nutrients
it's interesting because the kids
especially would prefer their muesli
with milk but the yogurt
so much better for them i like making it
literally
10 minutes before i want to serve it
because it doesn't become stodgy
yoghurt in apple juice that's a great
way of sweetening
the muesli a couple of tablespoons in
give that little mix now
sprinkle in the oats
i like putting two thirds in now to
absorb
and almost double in size and the last
third
of oats in at the end oats are low on
the glycemic index
which means they slowly release energy
to keep you going right through to lunch
i quite like it when it just falls off
the spoon
you can see literally in seconds it's
got thicker
the rest of the oats in
so i've got different textures now mix
that up
nicely and it literally takes three or
four minutes to put together
let's get a dry pan on almonds
incredibly healthy toasting them even
better flavor flake them into the pan
lightly toast them that gives a really
nice sort of
crunch to the top of the muesli
roll them around the pan so they're
evenly toasted
out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries
summer raspberries strawberries and so
it changes
berries don't just taste great they're
packed with antioxidants
and vitamin c and k so just dot
the top of your muesli with your
blackberries generous on the
blackberries
sweetness tartness acidic
and then just sprinkle over
your nice almonds i quite like
a lot of crunch on top so be generous
that looks fantastic
[Music]
perfect way to start the day
my quick birch muesli doesn't just taste
incredible it makes you feel fantastic
it's my ultimate healthy breakfast there
really is no better way
to start the day
i've never forgotten i think it was
about six years of age when mum brought
this huge
tray of eggy bread to the table and it
was like wow
man we've died and gone to heaven start
off with a slightly stale bread four or
five day old
loaf left over if it's a fresh bread
then it absorbs too much of the egg so
therefore it gets soggy you never get it
fried and crisp
and if you're not gonna use it with
breadcrumbs eggy bread is a must
in france they call it pan perdue the
lost loaf
now eggy bread is great on its own but
serving it with stewed apples
is delicious so the secret here keeping
the skins on
it's a lot of flavor in the skin and
also it stops the apple from breaking
down too quickly
they get these nice chunks as opposed to
a sort of apple puree
now get your pan nice and hot and
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar
take the sugar down to a light caramel
it's quite incredible how cheap it is to
make this and yet it was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
don't be scared to mix a pear and an
apple a banana and a pineapple
just chew it lightly toss in the caramel
get a little knot of butter that makes a
nice
toffee apple flavor really simple
now you can see what's happening the
apples are caramelizing but they're
staying intact because the skins on the
apple
and the caramels turn into this nice
rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water in there
bring that bowl and let that cook out
now the eggs
three whole eggs
[Music]
whisk up the eggs add about four
tablespoons of milk you want the
egg thick and rich and then lightly
sprinkle in
a couple of tablespoons of sugar that
sweetens up
the mixture and when you start frying
the bread
it caramelizes it beautifully a teaspoon
of
powdered cinnamon that gives the bread
that really nice spicy
deliciousness apples are
glazing beautifully and put them on a
low heat
and get a pan on now for the bread a
teaspoon of oil
and stops the butter from burning butter
in
as that starts frothing get your bread
in
it's going to be pretty quick now now
you don't leave the bread soaking
[Music]
and in the pan
[Music]
once your egg bread has browned flip it
over
90 seconds each side that butter gives
that nice
golden brown color of that egg
beautiful absolutely beautiful
[Music]
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now my apples they've all glazed
beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over
mmm wow if my mum saw me doing this
she'd kill me you're getting all posh
again no no
i'm using a touch of iced sugar to make
it look stunning
and that for me takes me back to when i
was six years of age
and i thought i'd just won the lottery
that is incredible thank you brett
[Music]
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread
with quick stewed apples
you think of the flavor and the texture
of avocado
rich phenomenal i want to make it a
little bit more vibrant
black sesame seeds a nice pinch of chili
flakes
i quite like it hot a touch of salt
and a touch of pepper so that nice dry
combination of the lemon zest
black sesame seeds and the heat from
chili this is
light healthy quick but so tasty
sourdough bread three nice chunky
thick slices open them up lightly season
them
little touch of olive oil brings the
whole crust to life
and rub all that seasoning in but you
can use
chipotle you can use a baguette but the
richness from the sourdough with the
silky creaminess of avocado
is mind-blowing and then get the grill
up to temperature
and push these down go the extra mile
we've all put bread
in a toaster but the difference of
grilling the bread this way
is extraordinary that nice smoky
charcoal flavor
off with the gas beautiful now the
avocado
you've got to treat them with love
respect press on the end here
and your thumb softens you can tell that
avocado is ripe never press here
you just end up bruising it slice down
until you feel that stone in the middle
and then just
roll around and then it's just a little
gentle twist
off stone
and out cut them into quarters the back
of your knife
peel back that skin if the avocado is
nice and ripe
it should just all fall away slice
just take your quarters fan them out and
push them into the bread
the ripe of the avocado the better the
flavor but look for ones
free from soft spots and blemishes which
can suggest bruising
get your lemon squeeze
that will stop the avocado from
discoloring and then get your
crunch ready to go on top
sprinkle in a very generous
light way we've got the fragrance from
the lemon zest
the crunch from the sesame seed the heat
that little chili flake
which just wakes up the avocado they
look
expensive that for me is a delicious
light start to the day
[Music]
[Applause]
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle
you